All black people aren't going to be the same.
Cool.
And I agree with you and that's why I'm going to disagree column.
I don't need that kind of foolishness around what's up,
run over here.
I thoroughly enjoy fragile.
I love it.
You know,
I understand the stereotypes about it and all that kind of stuff,
but I love it.
I just don't really like fried food.
I'm not really a fan of chicken.
I've never ate it.
So
you've never had fried chicken?
I have had it.
I just,
I don't enjoy it.
I don't really eat fried foods.
I try to eat pretty healthy.
So
there's nothing wrong.
Three,
two,
one
silly.
I'm always on the wrong side of the room.
Would you guys be excited if I had dreads since I'm biracial,
since I'm half black and half white.
So where is the line?
Like if someone's a quarter black,
I'm not going to sit there and come to your face and be like,
you're not a hundred percent black,
therefore you can't.
Like that's not my place.
However,
um,
if you a white person and you have dreads in her hair,
it's like what?
What does,
what does that mean to you and you're not even wearing them,
right?
Like you don't even wash them.
I just don't see how race can own a hairstyle.
It to be honest,
like pairs,
hair,
there's all kinds of hairstyles in Africa.
I still don't think that like a single race group can say this one hairstyle.
Nobody else can do it but me.
Oh Jesus.
Wow.
This cookout needs to just die.
Like I know for Cook outs,
no bra just go home.
Like they ain't no cookout.
I'm sorry.
I I strongly agree because I don't like the idea of perpetuating this concept
that all black people have to be the same and think the same and act the same.
I don't think he's fully understood.
People like Kanye or creatives and he uses like creative speech and some people
just take him at face value,
like uh,
like kind of like the literal sense of what he's saying.
And if you did that,
every creative could be taken the wrong way.
I disagree with that either.
Like I don't think that he's so creative and that has words are being
misinterpreted.
Like he's making very specific phrases like black people chose to be slaves.
That's completely untrue.
And in my opinion,
that's just unacceptable.
But I think that's,
that's people misunderstanding what he said.
I don't think,
how do you interpret that?
Well,
he's saying is there,
there's a,
there's a mindset,
um,
where,
you know,
we were
so okay.
Like he was trying to say it in the term of like,
you know,
it was a choice for you to stay there when you knew that you could have done
whatever else to get out and maybe you would have ended up dead,
but it would have been better than being asleep.
So I don't,
I don't
like this is the gates,
the millions of people who did
there.
Don't you believe that today there are people whose mindset their corporate
slaves or there or there
the language you use kind of guy.
He's an artist.
He's a lyricist.
So you can't say stuff like that because having learned that history yet,
and some people don't know that it was millions and millions and millions of
blacks who fall,
present,
fall asleep,
you're right in that he needs to be more conscious of his word choice because
there's not everybody who's going to understand that.
And that's why I say somebody is smart.
It's Kanye.
I think he's doing this for shock value and for money.
And if he's doing that he said and people back and that's why I can't rock with
him on that
scares me.
Is the second somebody big in PC or not or they or they're able to articulate
what they're trying to say.
Well or not that they're excluded from cookouts and from,
from a culture and from,
from your identity.
And I think that's scary because I'll tell you right now,
the more we treat people who are different and isolate ourselves,
even I think the worst of this for us long term,
and to be honest,
if we're going to drive more and more people to have closeted feelings and
emotions,
and this goes back to people saying like,
like would you rather have a racist next to you that's hiding it or would you
rather have a racist next to you that's letting you know how they feel and you
know where they're coming from.
Who and I agree with you and that's why I put it.
That's why I'm going to disagree column.
He could come and visit me.
He wants me to have some conversations,
but right now I don't need that kind of foolishness around the children.
Hawaii
three,
two,
one
I said strongly agree.
It was created to monitor the minority in the group.
Back in the day it was the Irish,
it was scallions and so it's ingrained into the system of policing and that's
the problem.
I think we got to reframe what policing is now and until we do that,
it will always be targeting people of color because that's what it was created
to do.
Um,
I see it as like,
there's a little bit of a socio economic piece to it.
It's like kind of saying the SCC mostly prosecutes why people through like years
of institutional racism,
you know,
where there's poverty and there's communities that are kind of like,
have created this like the perfect storm of,
um,
of issues.
Like whether it's legal issues,
people robbing each other,
selling drugs or whatnot.
You know,
the idea is if you police that neighborhood more and you're going to have more
of them arrested.
Can I ask you the,
can I ask you like,
do you feel like there are equal amount of arrests happening on Wall Street?
The none are happening in the hood,
like the white collar crimes are,
are,
I do think that there are less like monitored and less without having all the
data that I need,
but I do feel that,
that they don't suffer as much consequence when they,
when they come here.
Very true.
You got to look at in the prison industrial complex here too,
in the u s that's huge business.
So,
and if you look at a group of citizens that have been perceived as no value
having to society or whatever,
okay,
boom,
we're gonna push them.
We going a pipeline them into that system.
Yeah.
I also think that,
you know,
the qualifications to become a police officer are so low and it's like my life
is literally in your hands,
man.
Like if I get pulled over,
maybe that will be the day that I go home to be with the Lord.
And I think that that's really tough for me because you don't want to be
distrustful of the police,
but they're so incredibly distrustful of us that it's like you could literally
kill me.
Um,
my father,
what worked in law enforcement and he's a black man.
Um,
so there are some law enforcement officers that don't feel that way.
However,
I think a lot of it does have to do with fear and the fear of black people.
So I think that if we kind of address that fear level on that we didn't portray
black people,
especially black men,
is,
you know,
big scary guys that that would change a lot of stuff.
Two,
you will walk in which one?
I agree that I act differently around people that aren't black just because like
corporate America doesn't want to hear me talking.
Uh,
it doesn't wanna hear me speaking in slang and I am not happy about it.
Like I wish that it was different,
but I feel like I need to do to fit into that group.
I strongly disagree.
I am me wherever I go.
I'm a proud black man and I'm gonna speak my truth every day in a week.
If you don't like it,
she had an ain't on me.
That's on you.
And I feel like it's a disservice to anyone.
I'm around him from not being authentic self because my white friends might want
to hang out with me because I'm black.
They want some flavor.
So if I go in and being something totally different things,
just different things.
One thing is are you changing yourself or are you changing how you're
communicating who you are and I'm changing.
I'm communicating who I am and I still remained the same.
Like do you have a white voice?
Do I have a white horse?
I know,
I know Cole.
I'm a black man.
Trust me.
Every,
every black person growing up in America can code switch.
Then to move a little bit.
Here's the thing.
The question was do I act different when I'm in different surroundings and know?
We'll see how would I ever be accepted if I'm always cold switching,
that means I'm always acquiesce into something else.
You see what I'm saying?
So in order to be accepted,
you got to bring you.
Do you guys,
when did you say code switch?
Do you mean you change the actual words you say or do you mean you change the
tone of your voice?
Actually how I say it and I changed what I say I will,
I'll walk into a business meeting different than how I walked into the
basketball court.
So that's me changing to fit the citizen scenario.
The benefit,
the end goal.
And I don't view that as a negative.
I view that as me focusing on what the end goal is.
But I feel like society has made American society has made black people operate
in that fashion because nobody asks us white people to code switch.
They can breathe,
they can be white in America,
China,
wherever they accept they were around like visa.
But I'm the only one that has to go around and say,
oh hi,
how you doing it?
Three
collaborate.
Yeah,
glad that we all strongly agree.
Yeah.
I love that.
You know,
we can have these discussions and still go home knowing that we're family and I,
and I love,
I love being black.
I love that blackness is expressed in many different ways.
It's not just one way.
I'm proud to be biracial.
I am proud of my immigrant half.
How does my black Hass,
my ancestors brought their own freedom from slavery.
Yeah,
I'll,
I love being black.
I wouldn't have it any other way.
Um,
I mean,
yeah,
it presents its challenges,
but I couldn't fathom being something else.
So I am very proud to be an African American in America.
The comment section is going to be blown up when these habits alone.